BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So I'm going
to jump into some questions
before we get to your all
questions, just to seed things.
So Trey, we mostly know
you as a photographer.
That's your sort of main thing.
Why are you writing a book about
staying zen on social media?
TREY RATCLIFF: Right.
Well, that is--
90% of business is
fine art, and then 10%
is sort of social media.
So I accidentally became
an expert at this.
And I've noticed that there
is an incredible amount
of suffering out there.
And I think it's
important for people
that are able to reduce
suffering in the world,
I think it's good to do that.
That's a good thing.
And of course, there's many
categories of suffering.
There's real suffering,
like civil wars or hunger,
this sort of thing.
But I've noticed in the
last three or four years,
there's a new kind of
suffering, the suffering that's
brought about by social media.
So I'll tell you
this funny story.
It's a personal story.
I became a full-time artist
12 years ago, when I was 35.
Before that, I was IT computer
science, very left brain.
So I made this transition
to being a full-time artist.
And I was talking to
this wise old lady.
And I was asking her for advice,
because she was an artist.
She goes, Trey,
you will encounter
a massive amount of suffering.
Most of it will be self-imposed.
And that's what it is.
People heap suffering on
themselves when really it's
a fictionalized reality.
It's not real suffering.
And so when I see people
suffering anxiety online,
now it's been exacerbated
and accelerated
by the way social media works.
You're constantly being
reminded that you're not enough.
And this feeds
off what I feel is
a problem with humans
that you can't overcome,
which is an ego.
You tell yourself this
story about yourself.
And when things don't
match up with that story,
it causes you a massive
amount of anxiety.
So I became like an influencer.
I didn't know what that was.
I remember like 10 years ago,
I was speaking at this travel
photography conference.
And we had one of these--
right afterwards, we had one
of these dreadful cocktail
parties, where people
are mixing around.
This nice, well-meaning
lady came up to me,
and her eyes were
as big as saucers.
And she goes, are you
an influencer like us?
And I was like, what the
fuck is an influencer?
[LAUGHTER]
I can't even influence my
kids to clean their room,
so I don't think so.
Then I started to run into
more and more of these people.
Some were legit.
And some, they didn't
quite fit right.
You know, I like to
have deep conversations.
And so I would talk to them,
and I noticed sometimes
there was a lacking, a
hollowness, something
that wasn't there that should
be there, no substance.
And then I started looking
into it more and more.
And I realized that a
lot of these people--
because I work in the
luxury travel industry--
are faking it.
They might have bought their
followers, bought their likes,
bought their comments.
And then they approach
these big brands.
And then they ask
for a lot of money,
and free travel,
and all this stuff.
And then they put
these things online
that they're having
the perfect life.
And this, in turn,
causes a massive amount
of anxiety online.
But it's all based
on a false narrative.
So they end up spawning
a bunch of copycats.
And now there is
what I consider to be
this mass delusional behavior
of everyone pretending
to have the perfect life.
They all know that it doesn't
ring true in their hearts,
so that causes them anxiety.
But everyone else that doesn't
have a perfect life, which
is pretty much everybody,
they feel more like losers.
They feel like if they only
had these things in their life,
then they could be whole people.
But this entire thing is
based on a false narrative,
that you don't need
any of that to be
a complete person, that you're
already a complete person.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So
a lot of questions
emerge from the narrative
you just put forth.
One of them is what--
and again, these are deeply
philosophical questions,
but what compels people to
feed on this sense of lack?
Like, you know, if it really
is diminishing me and making
me feel worse, why can't
I put the phone down?
TREY RATCLIFF: Right.
Well, that's a good question.
Who is the "I" that is
putting the phone down and not
putting it down?
The more you study mindfulness
and consciousness--
and I'd recommend
books by Eckhart Tolle,
"The Power of Now" and "A New
Earth," Michael Singer's--
what's that book called?
I'll think about
it in a minute--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Google it.
TREY RATCLIFF: Gosh darn it.
Yeah, google it.
Can anyone google that?
Anyway, so these help you
to realize that you are not
the voice in your head.
You're the silence
behind the voice that
can watch the thoughts go by.
And you'll notice that
whenever a thought goes by
or you see something
online, and it gets stuck,
and it bothers you,
you, like, notice, oh,
isn't that interesting
that's bothering me.
Why is that bothering me?
Well, as stuff passes
by you, it gets
stuck on this egoic construct,
this framework that you've
built up in your
brain about your life,
and the groups that you believe
in, what you believe in.
And when you see something that
comes in that doesn't match it,
that makes you angry,
or it makes you upset.
And what's actually
happening there
is your ego just
reinforcing itself, saying,
I have the right story.
I find that to be wrong.
And it makes it-- it makes
the monster even bigger.
And you stay on to look
for things that will make
it stronger or more defensible.
This is why you stay
online because you
have come to identify
yourself with the stories
that you tell
yourself in your head.
And social media now
is so good at either
going against these stories
or for those stories.
It only reinforces what
you think is yourself.
But that's not your true self.
Your true self is one
without any of these thoughts
or preferences.
You could be the dolphin
that swims in the waves.
And so many people get caught
up in so many things that
bother them all day, and they
continue to complain online.
If you notice-- I
notice this-- that a lot
of positive, loving people don't
even spend time on a Facebook
anymore, because it
just becomes sort
of this cesspool of complaining.
And if you read comments
anywhere, even YouTube,
especially Facebook
or whatever, you
see that there's like this whole
new group of idiots out there.
And I consider this to
be like the Cambrian
explosion of idiot species.
We've never seen like--
oh, look, there's a guy
that's an anti-vaxxer
and a flat-earther.
That's a new species.
And so these
platforms that we use,
they've accidentally reinforced
some of these ideas, which
may or not be true.
Like, there are good
ideas out there and groups
form around them.
And there are bad ideas,
and groups form around them.
Like examples of good ideas
are like, the Dallas Cowboys,
gardening club,
board gaming club.
These are good ideas and
groups form around them.
And people share in
positive, loving ways.
And then there's bad ideas.
And those get
spread even quicker.
And a lot of bad ideas form
groups, where the groups
are against the other groups.
Like the board
gaming group, they
don't care about the
Dallas Cowboys group.
They're not saying, oh
man, I hate those Cowboys.
The Cowboys ar
saying like, god, I'm
glad we don't play video games.
There's like the loving
positive idea groups.
And these other ones,
which reinforce themselves
by destructing other groups.
And that's not good.
And the ego-- you have a choice.
Like where do you want to be?
Do you want to be in a positive,
loving place in which there's
so many great groups?
And the internet can
be an incredible thing
for spreading that.
But a lot of times, I think we
had this Pareto distribution,
of like 20% good stuff
to 80% bad stuff.
And there are bad
aspects of human nature
that are based on fear,
and a lot of these things
that are reinforced by the
media, which, you know,
you don't have to be
scared of all this stuff.
You can go into a loving place.
And so people end
up in these groups.
And then that's why
they can't put down
their phone, because they're
seeing things that make them
angry, make them really
happy, when really, none of it
has to really
matter in your life.
You can be the silence
behind your thoughts.
You don't have to be this
all-consuming assemblance
of groups that define you.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So in terms
of our personal responsibility
and accountability towards
remedying this situation,
I can think of a few recourses.
One is to shun
technology altogether,
to basically say this leads
to an unhealthy place,
I'm going to opt out.
Another would be to attenuate
it, and sort of say everything
in moderation.
I'm going to use some
of the tools that Google
and others are putting forward
to monitor and regulate,
similar to food.
There's an RDA for these things.
And I'm going to sort of be
very disciplined and thoughtful.
Another would be to
change the way I relate.
So you talk a lot about zen.
So as opposed to
shunning technology,
is there a way to
partake of it that
is less destructive or
less negative in terms
of my own reaction
to these things?
And then finally,
there's sort of unfollow.
So I can be more
thoughtful in terms
of what I expose myself to.
And I imagine
there's a spectrum.
As you're saying, there's sort
of very destructive groups
and then there's others
that are sort of healthy.
So I can have a
responsibility to sort of turn
the dial toward the healthy
and away from the destructive.
Like, is it all of the above?
Like, what is your
approach towards health
and our relationship to media?
TREY RATCLIFF: As
all the parents
that are out there know
this, you want your kids
to end up with the good kids
that are out there playing
the good sports, that have
positive habits, that sort
of thing, because they will
start to feed off of that.
You don't want them becoming
part of the bad group.
But think the same
thing for yourself.
Have the same
desires for yourself
that you have for your kids.
You want to be part of the
good, positive, loving groups
because the brains are
incredibly plastic.
And the more good,
positive, loving
stuff you have come into
your world, the better.
Like, surround yourself
with friends that want
the best for you.
I want the best for you.
You want the best for me.
This is sort of a mindset shift,
because all this same stuff
is on social media.
Now, on the other side of it,
I grew up with social media
being a creative,
a photographer.
And I would hang out with other
photographers and creatives
online.
And so a creative--
and it doesn't matter.
When I say creative,
you can do anything
from bake cookies to-- there's
all kinds of creative pursuits
out there.
It doesn't have
to be visual arts.
It could be audio, whatever.
I found it very natural
to make a creation
and then share it online.
In the same way that
my little girls,
they would make something
out of construction paper
and put glitter on it.
And then they would run around
the house and show everybody.
There's no ego involved.
It's just pure creation.
And it's said that a creation
doesn't exist until you
share it with the world.
I think that's true.
And so I was with all these
other creatives online,
and we were all sharing.
And I would sometimes
get negative feedback.
Actually, I would often
get negative feedback
because my photos were quite
controversial, because I would
do things in a different--
not different, because I
wanted to be different,
but just it felt right.
I was very interested in light
and the way it affected people.
And so early on, I
developed a very thick skin
because I received so
much negative feedback.
And I was wondering about that
because I know a lot of people
are scared.
And if you get
negative feedback,
it just feeds that healthy
self-doubt that we all have.
Like, yeah, maybe
I'm not so good,
and all this sort of stuff.
And again, that's just your ego.
Notice when things bother you.
And say like, I'm a good person.
I'm trying.
I may not always be successful,
but I'm a good person.
So I think if you go into
it with that mindset.
And the second thing is, you can
notice the negative comments,
but a way not to let
him get to you is--
and this is a little
hokey, but stick with me.
I think about this
definitely in creative.
And actually, it is
sort of this zen thing.
We're all flowers, and
we're growing, right?
And as you grow,
your petals come out,
and you get whipped
around by the wind.
You know, it's
kind of bothersome.
You have rain hitting you.
You have all this
stuff going on.
But you're OK with
it, you just grow.
That's what you do.
You're a flower.
You just keep growing.
You notice the
rain and the wind,
but you don't let it get to you.
So it's sort of this--
I have this idea of like,
you're a work in progress.
I'm a work in progress.
Don't listen to that
negative stuff out there.
And you're going
to be just fine.
Surround yourself with
positive, loving people
that want the best for you.
And just notice when you're
in a cesspool of negativity.
You'll notice online
that complainers
tend to stick together.
Someone says, oh,
let me tell you
about this problem I'm
having with so-and-so.
And then the next complainer
will come aboard and say, like,
oh, you think that's
a problem, listen
to this problem I'm having.
So this is just--
this is not a good, positive
space for the human mind to be.
And there's so many
great places you can go,
where you can be
supported, where you don't
have to spend the whole day--
imagine going the entire
day without being bothered
by anything, and just
like loving things,
and having awesome
people in your life.
Isn't that what we all want?
And you can slowly
make that choice,
make little
improvements every day
to change where you
spend your time.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So
it sounds like most
of what you're talking about
is changing your relationship
to the content and
being determined
in how it affects you.
Do you also, in
terms of absolutes,
monitor your own screen
time on a daily basis?
Do you think that's good, bad?
Is it a muscle we need to build?
Or is that sort of a
different dimension?
TREY RATCLIFF: I spend
most of my time creating
and very little time consuming
what's on social media.
I do pay attention to
a few close friends.
I think it's a good
idea to unfollow
people that aren't bringing
positivity into your life,
and just people that
are inspirational,
and give you good ideas, and
help you be a better person.
Because I get inspired by
people like that all the time.
And also one thing to note
is that the algorithms--
Facebook algorithms, and
Instagram, these sorts
of things--
they're unconscious.
They now serve up
ideas to you that
can aggravate you and cause
you to have a response.
And the algorithms don't
know what it's about.
And you're going to
get more and more
of that stuff in your feed.
The longer it stays
on your screen,
the more you like
it, the more it
makes you happy, the more
virulent things you type
in there, that kind of
stuff, it's reinforced,
because they want you to stay on
the screen as long as possible.
Because the longer you're on the
screen, the more ads you get.
And the more it takes you
away from mindfulness.
Mindfulness really has
nothing to do with the screen.
Mindfulness is a nice
walk through the park,
looking at trees, where there's
no past or no beginning.
There's no past,
there's no future.
And this is not
natural human behavior,
because this is
causing you anxiety.
I was talking about this
with one of my friends.
I live in New Zealand.
And he was having
some anxiety issues.
And he spends a lot
of time on the screen.
I said, look, dude,
think about it.
Just 5 or 10 generations ago,
we would not be doing this.
We'd be walking
across New Zealand.
We'd be out fishing.
We'd be talking to each
other, telling stories.
We'd be carrying some
rocks back or whatever.
We'd be setting up a
fire for the night.
We would light that fire.
As it gets dark, we would cook.
We'd all sit around the
fire and look at the fire,
and we would all tell stories.
No anxiety, this is a very
natural way of being human.
And I have this new
theory, by the way,
that because 99%
of our generations,
they would sit around a fire
every night and tell stories,
this is what the
screen has actually
replaced because it's bright.
It's at nighttime.
And it's telling stories.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So
speaking of influencers,
Yuval Noah Harari's
concept of fiction,
how does that relate to ideas
of followers, likes, comments?
What's the relationship there?
TREY RATCLIFF: So he has
three great books out,
"Sapiens," "Homo Deus" and "21
Lessons for the 21st Century."
And he has these great concepts.
I read a lot of books about
anthropology and history.
It's one of my hobbies.
And by the way, he
attributes his insights
to doing 30-day
silent retreats, where
he has such clarity
of thought that he's
able to have these ideas.
And one of the central
ideas in his books
is that humans are the only
animal on the planet that
can cooperate with strangers,
because we all collectively
believe in fictions.
Like, we all believe in an
hour, which doesn't exist.
You can't see it.
You can't touch it.
But it makes it convenient
to say, hey, Bradley,
I'll meet you at
Google at 1:00 PM.
There's no such
thing as a meter.
thing as a dollar.
But we all agree on the
story of these ideas
so that we can cooperate
with strangers.
It's why chimps can't
cooperate with strangers
and all this kind of stuff.
So this makes it special.
We believe in fiction.
So there's many stories, good
stories, that we believe in.
There's some bad
stories we believe,
but there's mostly good stories
that allow us to cooperate.
Now as much as the hour, the
meter, the pound isn't real,
neither is the follow,
the like, or the comment.
However, we have developed
at a monetary system where
you can trade dollars for other
things that can't be measured.
And all of these
have a substance.
We all agree on the measurement,
how long a meter is.
Like, OK, you're
going to build me
a train that's 10 meters long.
We know what we're going to get.
But now if you can't
trust in the veracity
of a follower, a
like, or a comment,
that whole system falls apart.
And so systems that
depend on that,
they can end up like
Venezuela because it's almost
like a counterfeit currency.
And right now, people
kind of believe in it.
And people are--
I think they spent
$2 billion last year
on influencers on Instagram.
That's supposed to go
to $10 billion by 2020.
And if all this money is
going into a system that
can't be trusted, then what's
going to happen is not good.
I don't want to live in a
future where you can't believe
the numbers that you see.
It doesn't-- it
doesn't make sense.
And I think that
we can do better.
these organizations
would want to do
better because they
want to have a strong
internal economy that can
be trusted from the outside.
Yuval has this other great
podcast he did with Sam Harris.
And he was talking about trains.
And he said, you know, there's
a time before trains and a time
after trains.
Trains is a technology.
He says, trains don't
really care what they do.
People have used trains to
build communist infrastructure,
so they can carry goods from one
place to another across Russia.
It's been used in World
War II to take people
to concentration camps.
Trains have also been used
in Japan to take salaryman
from Tokyo to Osaka.
Trains, they don't care.
It's a technology.
So it's unknown how humans
will use technology.
And I'm drawing that analogy
now to social networks.
Like, they're out there.
Maybe we have no control how
people are going to use them.
That's a possible sad reality.
I like to think we do
have some kind of control.
But so far, it doesn't
appear that we do.
And we're just grasping to fix
things when it's way too late.
And that's not-- that's
also not the social media
world I want to live in.
I want to live in a
positive, awesome place
because it has the
potential to do
incredible things for humanity.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Well,
I want to talk about that
because I know you
self-describe as an optimist.
You've been pretty harsh on--
or realistic on people's
relationship to social media.
What do you see as the positive
side and the opportunity
for social media to enhance
and enrich people's lives?
TREY RATCLIFF: You know,
I'm a travel photographer.
I've been to all
seven continents.
I travel all the time.
And I know that travel has
made me a more gentle person.
I know it makes pretty much
everybody a more gentle person.
And the thing is, that I have
inserted myself into situations
that we're uncomfortable,
that I didn't understand.
Like, here's a little story.
I was in university.
And my dad took me to France.
And I just kind of
had been in the bubble
of the USA my whole life.
And when I went to France,
it was like different.
I was like, dad, why do
they do it like this?
You know, why do they put
mayonnaise on their fries?
What's wrong with them?
Just little things like this.
And he goes, son, it's
not better or worse,
it's just different.
I was like, oh, OK.
And so I continued
with these thoughts
as I travel around and see how
different parts of the world
do things in different ways.
It's just different.
And I'm not judging anymore,
and I'm very accepting.
And you meet people on the
individual level, kids,
grown-ups, and people are
generally really nice.
They want good for their family.
They want good for themselves.
They want good for their
friends and neighbors.
This is a universal human truth.
It's totally true.
There's a bigger specter
of ideas out there.
And these ideas
have made themselves
more prominent on social
media rather than just people
loving their friends
and wanting everything
to go for the best for them.
So if we can shift
around what we're
focused on, on loving our
family, helping our friends,
helping our neighbors, this
very natural human behavior,
I think this is something
the internet can do.
It hasn't been doing
that right now,
because that doesn't
seem very profitable.
But humans are
capable of so much.
It's done fantastic things.
There are great stories.
Like, I'm sure-- how
many tens of thousands
of engineers that were in
small little villages of India
have now ended up here
in Silicon Valley.
It's because of the internet.
Like, this is the idea
of spreading a good idea.
And there's so many
options for that.
It's almost-- I'm not sure what
the exact solution for it is,
but I know if on the
individual level, if each of us
choose to stay in more
positive groups and help
surround ourselves with
positive, loving friends that
are pushing us help to
expose people to new ideas.
I think that's really what
happened to me as I traveled,
is I saw so many ideas.
I saw so many things I
didn't initially agree with
and I thought, oh,
maybe that's not so bad.
And this is a truth
for all humans.
The more ideas you're exposed
to, the more conversations
you have, the more
it opens your mind
and makes you a more gentle
person, opens your heart,
keeps you vulnerable,
and keeps you
in that good place for humanity.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Tell us about podding?
What is podding?
TREY RATCLIFF: Podding-- this
is a somewhat nefarious tactic
I go through in the new book.
It's-- OK, what podding is,
it's mostly used on Instagram.
It's against their terms of
services, terms and conditions.
And it's when a group of people
get together and kind of cabal.
It might be 10 people.
It might be a
thousand people, OK?
And let's say they're in--
it happens in every industry,
you know, from fashion,
to travel, to cars,
to you name it.
But let's say they're
in a fashion pod.
There's a thousand of them.
Well, what happens is,
like, let's say, one of them
posts a picture of
themselves with a Prada bag.
Well, they post inside their
pod, which is usually a chat
group, like a WhatsApp,
or a Facebook group,
or somewhere else.
And what happens is
immediately everybody--
the other 999 have to in
within the first five minutes
and comment on it,
and like it, and they
have to do at least three
words, all this sort of stuff.
And then the algorithm
sees like, oh, this is
a hot post about the Prada bag.
And then it's more likely to
be seen in more people's feeds.
So I find this
unethical in many ways,
because, A, all
of those comments
are coerced because if you
don't do what this cabal says,
the pod does, you're kicked out.
And suddenly, you're
not getting as much--
as many followers or
as much attention.
So it's disingenuous.
And the second thing
is that if Prada
had paid for that or
something, that they're
seeing all these comments,
they're like, oh, wow,
you know, this is
a great influencer.
And also, to me, the
other fundamental thing
is, all the other
people that are just
putting a picture up
and trying, they're
at tremendous disadvantage.
And so I see so much desperation
out there, like, on Instagram.
People have a new business.
You know, maybe a new wedding
photography business, or maybe
they've opened a new
pastry shop in Baltimore,
and they just are trying
to get attraction,
and trying to get
interest, or whatever.
Meanwhile, people that
are gaming the system--
when you start to
have algorithms out
there that decide
what people see,
normal humans will
try to game system.
There's going to be all
kinds of bots out there.
They're getting
smarter and smarter.
They'll always be able to
outsmart that algorithm.
And it leaves like
normal, honest people that
are making good content
and want the best,
they're at a tremendous
disadvantage.
That's just one of
many negative things
I outline in the
book that's going on
that I think is rotten.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: In
terms of how these pods
self-organize and discover,
where does that happen?
Like, is that-- obviously,
they're in an arms race with
the spam and abuse team over--
TREY RATCLIFF: Right.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: --at
the platform level.
But how do they find each other?
And how do they develop?
Are they authentic people in
this case, or are they bots?
TREY RATCLIFF: In this
case, they're authentic.
A lot of the bad activity
on there is bots.
But this is authentic behavior,
although for unethical reasons.
Normally what they do is
they just contact you as a DM
and invite you.
I've been invited
to three or four.
I've never said yes.
I talked to my
friend, Gino Barasa.
He was invited to one.
He was excited, because
he was kind of thinking
he could get some action.
He did it for a while, and
he felt like it was rotten,
and he left.
And there's this website
called SocialBlade.com,
which keeps track of
follower growth over time
and all that kind of stats,
because that's the only way you
can really see over time.
And he shows me the time when
he dropped out of the pod.
You see his follower
count drop down,
his engagement dropped down,
all that kind of stuff.
So you see a quick ramp-up
as you join the pod,
then drop down.
And so you just
sit around and wait
to get invited because
it obviously makes--
like, let's say you're
in a fashion pod.
Like, we need to get
that gal that has--
that woman-- that has
100,000 followers.
If she joins us, it'll
be great for the pods.
They want high-level people.
They don't want people
with less followers.
But people with just
a few followers,
they really want to be
in there because it's
good-- it's good for them.
It's just a little bit of too--
and really, what
this amounts to is
people have to stay on their
phone 8 to 10 hours a day,
which many already do.
They're flipping
through Instagram,
typing for this ridiculous
system, that is coerced,
inauthentic, and unethical.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
A question-- and I
don't presume you
know the answer--
but do you feel
like the platforms--
and let's speak at an industry
level versus one company,
but the platforms are
complicit and actually
benefit from behaviors
like this in terms
of being attractive to
brands and things like that?
Or are they truly
in an arms race
where they're
doing the best they
can to stop and condemn these
behaviors, but it's hopeless?
TREY RATCLIFF: I
don't know if they're
complicit or complacent.
It's unclear.
They're not doing
much to curb it.
Every now and then,
every three months,
they have a big announcement
that we're going
to curb this kind of behavior.
But then I looked online.
Three or six months
later, it's now
mushroomed into
ten times as much.
Part of the problem is
they do want big numbers.
I think that looks
good for Wall Street.
They want people to stay on
the screen as long as they can,
because then they
get to see more ads.
I don't know if these are--
I don't know if you can
put moral judgment into it,
but I don't find
these to be great.
Because you're-- there's a
billion humans out there that
are using this stuff.
And you can make
a strong argument
that people are wasting
many, many hours a day,
countless days per month,
probably a few months a year,
in doing things that
you shouldn't be doing.
There's so many more
things you could
be doing that are
positive, that are
loving for your family, and
friends, and for the planet.
So in that sense, I do
kind of find it unethical.
I pose a few possible
solutions in the book.
One, which I don't think
they would ever do,
is adopt the Spotify,
Netflix model.
It's proven people are
willing to pay for content.
And I think that would be
great, because now people
would get their feed in
chronological order once again,
not get any ads.
Their profits might
drop, but they'll still
make billions of dollars.
And they will be
plenty profitable.
They're going to have to--
that's such a big pivot for
such these Queen Mary type
organizations.
They may not do it.
It's going to make the users
angry when they find out
they have to pay.
But the users are already angry.
Give them this option.
Say, here you go.
I think that's a
possible solution.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: We've
explored something
like that with YouTube
Red, that enables
you to pay a small
monthly fee, and you
don't get the pre-roll ads.
TREY RATCLIFF: Right.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: And
millions of people
have signed up for that.
TREY RATCLIFF: Right.
BRADLEY HOROTWITZ: Yeah.
OK, I want to turn it
over to both in the room,
we have runners with mics, as
well as we'll flip to the Dory
shortly.
AUDIENCE: So Trey, we've
done a couple of experiments
with applying machine
learning to photos,
trying to separate out the
good ones from the bad ones.
And one of the factors
that always comes up
as the strongest
is people really
like it when you turn
the HDR up to 11.
And so you were way
out in front on that.
But how do we know when
we're doing what people like
and when have you gone too far?
TREY RATCLIFF: Oh,
that's a good question.
Yeah, I think one
reason I was unpopular
as a photographer
is because I liked
very vibrant,
colorful photos that
had high dynamic range in it.
That spoke to my
retinex in my brain.
It just made a lot
of sense to me.
We're not supposed
to manipulate photos.
That was a bad thing to do.
It's a good question.
You know, I know
one thing for sure
is that the stats show that
if you put up a picture--
if you, yourself,
are in the photo,
it gets 30% to 40% more likes.
And people are so addicted
to this public scoreboard
of how popular you are,
or how important you are,
or how meaningful you are
as a human is somehow based
on your likes, that
people are drawn,
like, I better put
myself in the photo.
There was a trend that started
about five years ago, where--
I mostly do landscape
photography.
A lot of people started to put
themselves in the landscape.
You know, they would hold
out their arms outstretched,
like, I'm finding
my true meaning
in life and all this nonsense.
Or there would be like a
solitary shadow holding
a flashlight, like
considering life,
the universe, and everything.
And those always
got a ton of votes.
And I thought, well,
maybe I should start
putting myself in the photo.
I was like, that's
ridiculous, Trey,
you know, you would just be
following what other people do.
But like even I had
that temptation.
So sometimes I think
that what looks popular
may not always be the best
or like truly innovative.
So if you look at your--
if you look at stats
across the internet,
if you look at the overall
bell curve of like 10
million photos, and you see
which ones have the most
likes with machine
learning, you'd be like,
oh, OK, they all seem
to have a picture
of a person's face in there.
So then the algorithm
might go through like, hey,
let us help you find
your best photos.
It'll go through 1,000 photos
you took over the week,
and it will only
serve up pictures
with your face in
it, which may not
be the most interesting photos.
They are to the
generalized bell curve,
but they may not be
the most interesting
because humans just
naturally respond
to other people's faces.
So you've got a whole
can of worms there,
trying to figure out what's--
because you may not want to
go to the middle of the bell
curve, because the middle
bell curve is boring.
None of us were
born to be boring.
None of us were born
to take boring photos
and share boring photos.
So you kind of look at these
trends on a meta level.
And to me, I find photography
is a great creative tool
that we all have
access to now that can
help you find your true self.
So you take photos of a
lot of different things.
And you kind of
choose what you like.
And you post-process
in a certain way.
And you might be
tempted to copycat
other people for a
while, but then you
start to find your own voice.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I have a
follow-up question to that.
In terms of finding
your own voice,
tools like Instagram
filters, Vasco,
have made it so easy
with one click or a swipe
to sort of post-process
and treat your photos.
And I think at first, it
was a big improvement over--
your crappy photos now looked
stylized and maybe crappy
on purpose.
But it's certainly
overplayed and takes away
some of that individual voice.
I mean, the dawn of
#nofilter is sort
of like this is authentic
and not overprocessed.
What are your thoughts
about empowering everyone
with the superpowers
of what used
to be the purview of
photoshopped jockeys and people
who could afford expensive
post-processing is now
sort of a swipe away?
What are your
thoughts about that?
TREY RATCLIFF: I
think it's great
if people want to use filters.
We-- a little plug here for a
product we made with Skylum.
We made this thing
called Aurora HDR.
It's on Mac and Windows.
And last year, we actually
won Mac's app of the year.
It has millions of downloads.
And like me, as a photographer
with a special technique,
why would I want to share my
special technique with millions
of people?
Because I know it's
not a zero sum game.
It makes the whole pie bigger.
And you can't teach millions or
billions of people meditation.
You can, but it's hard.
You can teach them
to be creative.
And I think when
you're a creative space
that you're being very present.
There's no past and
there's no future.
So I think if people are
using filters and having
fun, that's a good idea.
One thing that I would
say, future proofing,
is that this is not how you'll
interact with the world in 10
years, I promise you, OK?
Looking at a little
square, this is not
a way to look at a photo.
It's not-- it kind of
makes sense for the brain,
but it doesn't.
Like, if you've been
to a museum recently,
and you've seen like
a large format print,
and you physically have to move
your head around a landscape
to see it, this is natural.
Because humans standing
in a landscape,
you move your head around, and
you build a patchwork quilt
of what it's like.
Here, your eye is just
looking at one little thing.
And you can make almost
anything look good on Instagram.
Everyone's a great
photographer on Instagram.
But that may not translate
into the next layer, some AR,
VR combo, where we're
looking around a landscape.
There may be 3D
that comes into it.
So this whole world
of little filters,
I think it's good to
experiment, because now you
realize, oh, I can be creative.
Think about this as a stepping
stone for what everything
will become in the future.
I don't know what it
is, but it definitely
won't be looking
at a little square.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Well, I want to push
you to offer some ideas
about what it might
be beyond the little square.
You look at
synthetic photography
and even the pixel camera now
is able to do incredible night
photography using techniques
that are AI based.
What do you think might be next?
Is it combining modalities?
Like, do you want to
bring in sound, and depth,
and 3D modeling?
Or is it more in the
frame buffer and sort
of the processing of capture?
What do you think are the big
innovations in photography
that you're attuned
to or curious
about in the next 10 years?
TREY RATCLIFF: I love my
pixel phone, by the way.
I'm not paid Google guy, but
I love it, independently.
Well, people do like to
be visually stimulated.
And there seems to be
no limit to that, right?
The more visually stimulating
it is, the better.
A 4K is better than 10 EP.
And so it's all going
in that direction.
And we do have this bifurcated,
rectangular viewing system,
so that's why we tend to
like rectangular things.
And given the
preference, we would not
like to have any borders
around that, just like we don't
have any borders in real life.
The higher the fidelity
and the more realistic, I
think the more we'll like it.
There's going to
be stepping stones,
of course, until
we get to something
that feels as real as this.
But I think the
realer we get to this,
the more people will like it.
Now, of course, this means
some kind of VR topping,
or AR that goes black,
and gives you this.
I don't believe in 360,
because people are lazy,
and you like to sit down.
You're not going to be
turning around on cell phone
to see what's going
on behind you.
But I believe in 180.
Two modalities-- one,
I think will be--
maybe three-- and one will just
be a photo, just a still photo.
And like, wow, this
is really cool.
It looks perfect.
A second version of that
is one that's moving.
I think in landscapes,
but it could
be you're just sitting there in
Shibuya, the crossing in Tokyo,
and you're sitting there
just watching people go by.
Someone could even set up a--
Google could set up a camera
there that's just 180,
super-high-res, 10K around you.
And I would just probably
sit there on my couch
and just watch people cross
the street for hours, you know.
You can do the same
thing with a field
in New Zealand, where the
flowers are flapping around.
You see a bird
every now and then.
There's a mountain
in the distance.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Just a sort of portal
to another point in the world.
TREY RATCLIFF: Yeah,
you're just there.
And I think that can
be quite relaxing.
Because I know people
like to travel.
Not everyone can
afford it, but soon you
can do it in absolute
fidelity, almost as good.
Without going
through the trouble
of going through airport
security, and TSA, and all
that jazz.
You can have a
meaningful experience.
So mode one is a still picture.
Level two is having
motion, like with no story.
Level three is having
motion with a story.
Like you're sitting in
the middle of a play.
You're watching "The
Book of Mormon."
And you're just sitting
actually on the stage.
You can look around and
watch all these actors.
This could be all be all
new for storytelling,
all new equipment,
all new skills.
No one has created
these tools really yet.
So chances are
everybody in this room
and my kids are going to be
doing things that haven't even
been created yet with tools
that haven't been created yet.
Just like when I
went to school, there
was no digital photography.
There was no internet.
And now I'm doing it.
So there's going to be,
like, so much opportunity
for creativity.
And I know what people are like.
People love
consuming stuff, too.
I do think everyone
can be creative.
And I think this will give them
an opportunity to play around
with being creative.
Just like right now, they're
doing things on their phone,
they'll have some device that
they can capture the world
around them, and
they can share it,
and people can see their world.
They can have all new
levels of creativity.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So if
you do have a question,
it would be helpful
to move to the aisles
while Trey's answering.
In the back, please.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
how you reconcile
the treatment of places
of natural beauty
that are maybe not well known.
You're trying to share and
celebrate these locations,
but then you're giving away
location and destroying it,
like "Sunset Magazine," the
pristine beach, or trail,
or campground.
You show up on the
cover "Sunset,"
and it used to be that
was the end of that place.
And now Instagram is
destroying locations
when it attracts so many people.
And yet, you want
to share, right?
How do you cope with
that philosophically?
TREY RATCLIFF: That's
a good question.
There's been a lot of
stories now about what you
said, Instagram ruining places.
To me, that's an egotistic
thing, where people just
go get copycat photos.
So they get a
photo of themselves
in front of this famous
street in London.
And you just look up
and down the street,
and everyone's just taking
Instagram photos of themselves,
so they get more likes, and
they repeat what others--
this is what I consider to
be mass delusional behavior.
We've never seen this
in human history.
And I think the root of this,
by the way, is tied to our--
I'll think of the
word in a minute.
Our 150 people--
I know what you know--
that we have in our village.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
The Dunbar number.
TREY RATCLIFF: Yeah,
the Dunbar number.
The Dunbar's 150, which
comes from-- for 99%
of our ancestors, we lived in
villages with about 150 people.
You knew your immediate family,
your friends, the shaman,
the warriors, that
sort of stuff.
So your brain got wired to
keep track of 150 people.
If you think about
your real life now,
you can really keep track of
about 150 people, not thousands
and thousands.
And normally, for
99.9% of our history,
you've been around
those 150 people.
And you're checking
in, and you kind of
know people's relationships,
and that sort of stuff.
But now we're separated.
We might only have like 10
people around us that we know.
And we're kind of connected to
other people on the internet.
But you're also connected
to thousands, and thousands,
and thousands of people.
And so, whereas before you
wanted to put on a good show
to make sure you impressed
people in your 150 people,
to make sure they're
happy with you,
make sure you're being
a responsible member
of the tribe, that
kind of stuff,
and that you're attractive,
or whatever, that you're
doing something needed.
Now you're connected to
thousands or even more.
And people have this compunction
to impress strangers.
This never happened before.
So now you've defined
your self-worth
on what thousands of strangers
think about you, who will never
have any impact on
your life or whatever,
you'll never be friends with.
And if you don't
impress total strangers,
you find yourself unworthy.
So that's why people are going
out to do this kind of thing.
I think the problem more is with
the selfie kind of situation,
or people taking photos of
their friends in these places.
It doesn't happen quite so
much for landscape photography.
There is sort of this
roadside bingo thing
with landscape photography.
So you go to Tunnel
View in Yosemite,
and you'll see like 50 people
lined up to get the same photo.
That's not as
environmentally destructive
as some of these other things.
I tend not to do that.
I tend to go around the outside
and try different things.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Have
you ever obfuscated,
like you're not going
to reveal where this is?
Like have you-- or do you feel
like that's not necessary?
TREY RATCLIFF: No, I share
where it is, because people ask.
It seems wrong to say I'm
not going to tell you.
You know, that's seems--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
That's selfish.
TREY RATCLIFF: Mean.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
No, no, no--
TREY RATCLIFF: Yeah, but also
at the same time, I go out there
and profess like,
find your own places.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
TREY RATCLIFF: It's not--
it's not any great
accomplishment
to go copy a place that I took.
For example, this
is why I don't take
underwater photography
of like sharks, and whale
sharks, and coral, and
all this stuff because we
know Eric Chang.
He's so good at it.
It would take me 10 years to
be able to get to where he is.
I'm interested in it,
but I just can't do that.
So I kind of stick
with what I know.
And I like finding new places.
I like street photography,
because that's always
different.
It's always dynamic.
You'll never see the same thing.
I hope that helps.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Acknowledging the
"Sunset" effect
that was brought up earlier.
So you're visiting
Northern California.
A couple of your quick
favorite spots to go
shoot that you maybe already
have shot and anything
on your bucket list,
like around here?
TREY RATCLIFF: All right,
Northern California.
Down PCH, Highway 1, is a really
cute place called McWay Falls.
It's a little waterfall that
you can't see from the road.
And there's usually
not many people there.
I chose to reinvent the shot
by just going at midnight
when it was under a full moon.
And I thought it
was very romantic.
It looked like the
"Star Trek" set.
You know, the old school "Star
Trek," where it doesn't quite
look real.
Muir Woods is great.
Again, I consider it almost
like street photography,
because there's so many views
and it can be so unique.
Although, shooting in a
forest, is very difficult to
get the 3D-ness of
it into a 2D photo.
Oh, man, there's so
many great places
all in Northern California.
I've been doing some street
photography the last two days
and two nights in San
Francisco around Chinatown,
because you just see
interesting people there.
There's cool lights.
It's different.
In a way, it could be anywhere.
I like having photos
are a bit timeless.
They could be anywhere.
Gosh, that's all I can think.
Those are three off
the top of my head.
But if you go to my blog
and click on California,
you'll see a lot.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: In terms
of street photography,
I have a question.
Obviously, if you're taking
a photo of Shibuya Crossing,
you don't go and
tell everyone I'm
going to be taking
a photo of you
and get their affirmative
consent and things like that.
What are your feelings around
consent and capturing photos
of people in that context?
TREY RATCLIFF: I'm definitely
a bit of a renegade
on this and no authority.
But I do take a
lot street photos.
And I never ask for permission.
There's a caveat on that.
Because I want
them to be natural.
As soon as people know
the camera's on them,
a lot of people
get a little weird,
even if they're
trying to act casual.
Like, only a real model
can really act casual.
So you really lose the moment.
You lose-- you lose the
person or the people
and the way they're interacting
with this environment, which
it should be very natural.
Now, if I get a good photo,
which sometimes I do, and then
they noticed me, which sometimes
they do, I say, hey, guys,
I got a great photo.
Do you want to see?
And I show it to them.
I say, do you want me
to you send it to you?
99% of the time,
they say, no problem.
Same thing with Burning Man is
people are dressed crazy there.
You know, there's nudity
and stuff like that.
I go crazy taking photos.
I don't take nudes, because that
just seems a little gratuitous.
You know, I try to
be inventive and not
show those-- show those parts.
And I do it without
permission because people
are in their natural state.
You know, they're really
feeling their own sense
of self-expression, whatever
happens to be going on.
And almost always, I go
over, show them the photo,
and I send it to them.
I've only gotten like 1
out of 1,000 rejections.
Someone came up to me and
told me to erase the photo.
And it's because she
was a schoolteacher.
And she didn't want the
other parents to find out.
I said, hey, no problem.
She didn't say it in a mean way.
She's was like, totally cool.
I know what you're doing.
But I don't want
to get in trouble.
I was like, no problems.
So yeah, it's really fine.
Especially, I find that
the US is very fear based.
If there's a kid in
the photo, they just
assume you're some
kind of child predator
because the news media
has scared moms so much.
And I don't think
that's healthy.
When I think a lot
of photographers,
we just think kids are cute.
So now, I tend to take photos
more in Asia, in Japan, where
they don't think it's weird.
You don't get people--
people are just like ready
to be offended by stuff here.
You know, they think--
it's poisonous how
much fear there is.
And not just in the
US, but other places.
They just think like their
hackles are always up instead
of--
it's the total opposite
of Burning Man,
where you're walking around.
Everyone is just
there full of love.
No one's going to
come after you.
That's why I wish the world
was more full of love.
And I think it's up to people
like us to make that happen.
AUDIENCE: So a question
about post-processing.
So oftentimes, due to
post-processing, photographs
are warped from reality.
Sometimes I wonder
what was the reality
and what is the actual outcome?
Is there some standard that
photographers generally
should prescribe to, to indicate
how much processing has been
done, and how much
further of a photo
has morphed from the reality?
TREY RATCLIFF: Well, there's no
standard for any creative art.
Absolutely, that's sort
of a basic statement.
I'll tell you what I tend to do.
This is my thought process.
I think a lot about
kids and how they're
able to very quickly
go between what's real
and what's not
real effortlessly.
They have a very thin membrane.
They'll be talking about
dragons and all kinds of stuff,
and then suddenly you're talking
about having some pudding.
And they just go back
and forth, you know.
And it's not clear that
they're sure of the difference.
But as humans, we don't have
this thin membrane-- or as
grown-ups, we don't
have this thin membrane.
Our membrane gets thicker,
and thicker, and thicker.
And we're like, this is real,
and this is what's not real.
And you still enjoy
the fantasy, not real,
but you have to go into a
dark theater for two hours,
turn off the lights
so no one can see you,
so you can be alone,
and experience
this fantasy reality, which
you completely give up.
You say, like, oh, man,
this is a great story.
And you really get into it.
It doesn't matter
if it's not real.
And this is part of
my overall thesis,
is there's not a big
difference between what's real
and what's not real,
as long as it's
beautiful and full of truth.
So for my photos, I usually
like to walk that line.
Like, is it real,
is it not real?
And this causes a conflict
in the brain, as you wonder,
is it real or not real?
And I think this tension between
what's real and what's not real
is interesting.
Counterintuitively, with
art, especially photography,
is you want to confuse or
abstract the information
so that their brain has
to look at it for a while
to figure out what's going on.
I notice when I look at
Instagram or Facebook,
I stop on the photos that
don't quite make sense.
I'm like, what's going on?
Is this a shadow?
Is it a dress?
Where's the light coming from?
So those ones that are
mysterious, I stay on.
The phones today are so good.
You take a picture and
everything is totally literal.
There's no guesswork.
It's almost like a
courtroom drawing.
You see everything
that's there and the mind
has nothing to wonder about.
So I do what Pierre
Auguste Renoir did.
He would always purposely
obscure information,
or confuse information, or
have parts of his painting
that didn't make sense.
Because as you're
trying to work it out,
your brain doesn't
really like a mystery.
It will start to fill that
mystery with your own history.
Everything that you feel,
everything that you think,
your own stories.
So you're going to start
to build a story about what
this is about.
And as you're doing
that, you become really
intertwined with the art piece.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I recently
bumped into a listicle, which
was top 20 optical illusions.
And if you ever need a reminder
that reality is a construct,
anyways, so much of these
were just absolutely stunning
in terms of how much my brain
filled in or hallucinated,
given the right raw material.
So it's fascinating
that you deliberately
play with real and
non-real, because it's
happening all the time whether
we're aware of it or not.
AUDIENCE: What's your
advice for discovering
new content beyond
the mainstream
that everybody thinks about?
How do you find the next cool
thing to pay attention to?
TREY RATCLIFF: I
would try to follow
curators that are out there.
Like, not everybody
is a pure creator.
Some people are curators.
And they are following
new people all the time,
recommending new talent.
There's lots of great
websites for that.
And also, if you just
follow some artist
that you respect
and admire, they
will often mention other people.
Like, oh, he thinks these
people are interesting,
I'm going to go follow them.
That's probably my best advice.
Follow curators and trust
what your current network is.
Always be up--
I always say always be
upgrading your Dunbar 150.
You really only have to follow
150 really interesting people.
That's what your
brain is used for.
Same way with friends, try to
keep upgrading your friends.
Not to say your old
friends are bad,
but you deserve great friends.
You deserve great art.
You deserve to be inspired.
You deserve all these
things as a human.
I remember the name
of that book that I--
it's my number one
book recommendation.
It's called "The Untethered
Soul," by Michael Singer.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Thank you for that.
TREY RATCLIFF: Sure.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: And thank you.
I want to, on behalf of
all of us here at Google,
thank you for the work that
you do, both the art you create
and taking the time
to explain the process
and invite us into
your own journey.
It's incredibly generous
and incredibly helpful.
Thank you, Trey.
[APPLAUSE]